uh some things are really complicated in
the world and in politics
uh and they require deep knowledge they
require speaking to experts they require
understanding different disciplines and
considering
uh a lot of different components nuclear
energy
string theory post-modernism whatever i
think you understand
the right amount of taxation to balance
um not uh properly funding social
programs while not disincentivizing work
or whatever right there's
there's a lot of complicated stuff that
exists in life
we have a really simple grand theory in
front of us
which explains donald trump's behavior
as of late and it doesn't require
uh this deep and and nuanced knowledge
of anything like string theory or
taxation he is terrified that people
that you
i'm talking about people like you are
going to vote in november
and more specifically he's terrified
that you are going to vote for someone
other than him if you
just look at the last two three weeks in
american politics
just about everything that donald trump
has done publicly
relates to that fear which has become an
existential fear for him because his
political life depends on how
you vote in november don't imagine that
it's about how
other people vote it's about how you
vote you
have agency in this and donald trump is
scared to death
his political life that you might vote
for somebody else
donald trump demoting his campaign
manager brad parscale
because he saw he was losing in the
polls and he reportedly was on the phone
furious with par scale and ultimately
par scale
is demoted that is because donald trump
is scared
that he's going to lose if brad parscale
sticks in
as his campaign manager donald trump's
new tone on coronavirus which lasted
like three days which included
you know carrying around his mask and
saying it could get worse before it gets
better
a more sort of somber sober tone
it was just desperation to turn polling
around his idea was let's just ignore it
ignore it ignore it open up pretend
everything's going back to normal
that failed he knows that the failure on
coronavirus is one of the main
drags on his approval rating and so
he takes a new tone that's all it is and
it only lasted about three days
trump opposing vote by mail because he
thinks vote by mail will hurt his
re-election and it will i'm going to
show you the new polling data on that
trump correctly perceives if more people
vote by mail
that's probably not good for me it's
good for joe biden
he's right i will explain why so trump's
motivation to stop vote by mail by which
we really just mean expanding accident
absentee ballot access
his real motivation is not oh it's going
to be fraudulent or fraudulent as he
says
uh it's that it's just not going to be
good for him uh announcing that he's
banning tick tock could even relate to
this now will he ban tick tock
we don't know you know like like most
things we were supposed to get a new
health care plan yesterday we didn't get
it he announces many things that never
happen
comedian sarah cooper's videos about
donald trump
go giga-viral on tik-tok and
they really don't make trump look good
it was tick-tock
users that allegedly organized that
coordinated mass ticket request for
trump's
tulsa rally which ended up with a
two-thirds empty arena so
again going after tick tock could be
trying to look strong on china it also
could be that trump perceives that
it's going to help him in terms of his
election to ban tick-tock
kneecapping the post office by putting
in his
multi huge millionaire donor as the
postmaster general
if people are going to be voting by mail
delay the delivery of the ballots by
hurting the post office
perfect strategy right every action is
in the context of how can trump get
himself reelected
reportedly being open to help from
russia
china and either other countries and
we'll talk about that later today
there's a new
interview there which is completely out
of hand it's because trump is desperate
that he's going to lose and he'll take
anybody's help that he can get
and then in the end as trump realizes
that some people
are truly so committed to his removal
that they would crawl over broken glass
and dodge landmines to vote to remove
donald trump
he floats the idea last week of delaying
the election
now i have to tell you i wish i was as
confident that trump was going to lose
as trump seems to be that he's going to
lose in the sense that
you would only do all the things donald
trump is doing
if you were pretty reasonably sure that
you had a good shot
at losing this thing so while publicly
trump says we're doing great in florida
we're doing great in florida both of
them uh
etc he knows that really he's not doing
well and he knows that he may well lose
and i am not as confident as trump seems
to be that he is going to lose
over the last seven days some polls have
tightened up in trump's favor now it's
he's still behind
but it's it's still you know five weeks
to the election i'm sorry no
uh we're still two months three months
to the election i'm getting confused
we're four and a half weeks from the
first ballots being cast but we're still
almost three months from the election
three months to the day
um you don't want to see polls start to
tighten now that's a bad
sign now everybody has a different idea
about what drives donald trump
and i got some emails over the weekend
saying you know trump's worried that if
he loses in november
he's going to end up in prison i
actually don't think that he's worried
about that because i don't think there's
really any chance that it's going to
happen and i know that i continue to
hear from people who say
trump's going to get indicted for this
trump's going to get indicted for that i
don't think so i think that there will
be
some financial crimes for which
his companies maybe will be held
accountable with fines but
trump's not going to prison and anybody
waiting for that i think is going to be
waiting for
the rest of their lives this is simply
about
donald trump's narcissism donald trump
trump's delusions of grandeur
and the constant power trip that he is
on he doesn't
see himself as a loser and losing
is you know to use their language losing
his beta
i don't think trump in practice even
wants to be president he wants to be
president
in theory in terms of the power that
comes with being the president of the
united states trump is a cornered animal
who perceives a threat right now he has
the fight response rather than the
flight response the flight response
might be
i'm going to resign or turn things over
to mike pence or whatever before
uh this goes bad in november if indeed
that's what's going to happen trump has
the fight response
and we know from studying the animal
kingdom that this is dangerous territory
to be in
all of his actions from now until
november
should really be interpreted under this
framework and we just can't let him do
it it's actually that important
and the numbers that we now have
relating to vote by mail versus vote in
person
are a huge signal
about why on that issue trump is digging
his feet in the ground sticking his head
in the sand drawing a line in the sand
whatever metaphor or analogy i'm mixing
up here you all know what i'm talking
about
and deposing vote by mail let's talk
about that next
if you were anything like me you
probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into a doctor's office right now
and thankfully there's a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with no other fees or
copays
there are so many practical advantages
to using steady md for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with a doctor
who specializes in my particular health
needs and situation the doctor they gave
me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link right
underneath this video